hi i'm carl medlock welcome back to the
iced coffee hour and i don't know what
else i'm supposed to say so far the
podcast is made and just guess i guess
you guys made six hundred and eighty two
thousand three hundred fifty one dollars
on podcasts not bad uh two hundred and
three thousand three hundred and
eighteen dollars is how much money for
someone outside of the youtube thing
that was a pretty good guess i'm gonna
expect more out of you this year well
that's goal it's gonna be 650. 650.
let's do it by the end of this year
let's do it all we need is for you guys
to subscribe hit the like button comment
down below for the algorithm and uh
anyway we got a really exciting episode
today because this car behind me
i uh may have done a thing
and uh this is the newest addition to
the uh family got the uh 2010 tesla
roadster one of 26 in yellow and how
this all came to be is because i found
you on both cnbc and the what's inside
channel as the original tesla whisperer
you're the one who's keeping these cars
alive and you're also an integral part
to
the development of these cars and a lot
of the early history with tesla so today
we're going to be sharing some secrets
about elon musk tesla tesla and
everything else you didn't know that you
need to know is that a good intro oh i'm
scared
that's fun what number of uh what number
employee are you of tesla i would say
i'm probably in the 300s 300th employee
of tesla probably somewhere in the 300
range so walk us through your story and
how exactly you found yourself to that
place the quick version of the story is
i was a car dealer here in seattle but
when tesla was looking for somebody
to be their first employee outside the
california area what they did was they
were looking for a technician with a
master technician experience they were
looking for somebody who owned a
business previously and they were
looking for somebody who had managed a
dealership and they're looking for
somebody who had worked on high on cars
apparently i was the only person at
seattle that checked all those boxes on
linkedin and they contacted me and asked
me if i wanted a job i didn't know who
they were kind of laughed tesla hold on
while i google you and i typed i
literally was googling the guy as i was
talking as i was talking anyway long
story short was i turned the job down i
wasn't interested dealership was doing
great i didn't have any reason to
go anywhere else
and uh
the economy in 2008 kind of took a dive
and i ran out of inventory for my car
dealership and the phone rings and it's
uh matt giambruno from tesla motors uh
called back and see if i was interested
in that job and i thought well you know
what
absolutely been reading up on you guys
which i hadn't been reading up in you
guys i really look like i'd be
entertaining that the the idea of coming
to work for you and i'll take that free
trip to san carlos so that's what i did
what were those early days like for you
like what was your first day what do
they have you do
if you uh
if you're at a stop light and you just
mash your foot to the floor and you spin
the tires and eventually you get the car
straightened down that's kind of like
the first day's a tesla you literally
were running as fast as you could run
you're on an airplane you know somebody
call you hey where are you today that's
kind of one of the famous things was
where are you we actually my team would
use
we used facebook
messenger for private messages between
my entire team whoever was working with
me because if we did email then somebody
could read the email or whatever but if
we had something going on that we wanted
to get done um behind the scenes we
would just use facebook messenger chat
that way with everyone oh and so at the
time it was just the roadster
that was being sold correct this is
before the model s came out just the
roadster and like there was the one
prototype which people don't really know
this but the original tesla
model s prototype was actually an s 500
mercedes that had been lengthened
and a roadster drive train was stuck in
that model uh that uh s500 it was the
first model s it was white and it was
maroon and i don't know what colors all
the cars was that carpet came what was
your first impression of the roadster
when you first started working with so
i was actually driving a ferrari 360 at
the time and i was just uh
i went to work for tesla and i went to
san carlos to drive um for the interview
and they gave me a ride one of these
cars i instantly realized that you have
power right out of the hole as soon as
you mash the throttle you can take off
and you can you know the cars just
the difference between that and a
ferrari or a gas engine car was you have
to wait for the rpms to come up so you
get the torque pattern and you get up
into the torque curve and then you
actually had power so ferrari 360 you
were doing 70 miles an hour in first
gear before the car actually had any
real real power a tesla roadster has
power right off the bottom it's the same
as turnaround blender it's instantly on
and they're just fast they're quick did
you take the job for tesla before having
driven the car i did actually really i
never sat unseen really i had never seen
a roadster when i took the job how good
was their offer that you were willing to
because i know your car business was
somewhat going
wasn't wasn't going as well as you would
have liked but how good was their offer
as a company who at the time wasn't
doing that well either they were just
getting themselves out there very
competitive you know they kind of felt
me out you know i now i look back on
that and i and i think about what matt
the questions about jim bruno asked me
and you know they were feeling out what
your price point was what and you know
what they made me a very fair offer and
at the time you know i came from the car
dealership industry and the health
insurance you have at car dealerships
it's worse than not having insurance and
you'll spend two thousand dollars a
month per person and then have a six
thousand dollar deductible before you
can even start using the insurance it
was just awful and so i go to work at
tesla and
my my even my our medications were five
dollars it's the best insurance i've
ever heard so there was a lot of perks
that came with tesla and they gave us a
lot of stock options to start with i
mean they gave us 40 000 options
um some of us wow to start higher on it
was funny they uh talked about um
right after i was hired people i was
like yeah i just want to work for tesla
i'm so excited and then people said like
they just went through a layoff
i'm thinking oh wow that sucks
but that's when they ousted martin
eberhard and a bunch of other people
right in october of 08 right when they
were calling me to hire me right can you
say what exactly the offer was and
the decision and like why you decided to
do that instead of however much you were
making i basically took a 40 pay cut to
go to work at tesla the offer was 120
000 or maybe 125 i think and then it was
40 000 or 20 it was 40 000 options and
then they did a reverse split right
before the ipo which made him 20 000
options but still that's a lot of money
it wasn't at the time because my strike
price was 90 cents
the strike price was 90 cents
price
oh yeah i was like at 90 cents it was
going to take him seriously i mean
because i surely wasn't i mean like i
was i love the job but i didn't take at
90 cents who cares 40 thousand options
well i got 40 000 oop d you know that's
all it was back then but that's 50
million dollars today oh my gosh so yeah
what did you do with those options
well um i kept them and then i went
through a divorce and the divorce lawyer
uh convinced the judge that the tesla
was going to go out of business in 2013
and they sold them all no at 38 dollars
a share exactly what somebody else did
somebody else mentioned thirty eight
dollars this year yeah oh my god
that's the most expensive attorney i
think i've ever seen oh yeah it was you
know like water was 60 grand or
something at the time but now that's 50
million dollars
i actually did some research to see if i
had a case against the lawyer but i
don't
even though he made a he convinced the
judge that they're gonna go out of
business and we're gonna have to sell
the stock to pay his
lawyer fees
yeah i'm how often does that keep you up
at night
i mean at this point you can't do
anything other than just like the
absurdity of it well the good news is oh
my gosh i met you and i met a lot of
great people through these cars the bad
news i've been i've been retired i
bought myself a helicopter i've been on
some island that i owned and you know
nobody ever seen me again but now here's
the thing too is we're also assuming you
would have held through all the boom and
bust cycles and because a lot of people
say that with like oh i bought bitcoin
when it was ten dollars and now it would
have been worth all this money
realistically a lot of those people
would have sold it a hundred or a
thousand and you know and it let's say
if that hit 10 million dollars i mean at
that point it's like well i may as well
10 million dollars
but
it goes to show just how far tesla's
come i don't really sell anything like i
have a bunch of lucid stock a bunch of
rivien stock as well i don't really sell
anything i just like to buy it and then
if i can afford it and if i can afford
to lose the money i'll buy it yeah but
then i just then i forget about it don't
think about it so your initial offer was
120 and then you obviously i'm sure
continued on this tesla journey what was
it like over the next couple of years
working at tesla and how did your
position in the company scale it was the
most fun
job i've ever had and i'll tell you why
um
first off you have a new
you have a new topic you have electric
cars and it's a support car it's fun
it's fast and you get past all the
mocking you know where do you put the
gas you know all that stuff and that was
the early on and that but it became fun
because you're working with the best
people if you know for example the way i
was hired i had like six or seven
interviews and every one of those
programs could have kicked me out said i
wasn't capable or or the right person
right fit
but then i went through all those and
then i had to interview with elon as
well and i interviewed with elon and he
asked me customer service stories you
know what was what was your best
customer service experience what was you
know this what was that and then uh so i
got the job based on what they had
learned right then and then the other
aspect of the job was i actually had
worked with a guy in 1998 here in
seattle
and he was one of my final interviews
there and i didn't recognize him and he
looked at me this guy's six five ish
black belt in jiu jitsu you know the
type of guy i'm looking at you know it's
like a dark cloud in the doorway and uh
he's standing in the door when he goes
i'm not gonna review this guy
i thought well had a good trip see you
later
and uh it ended up being that um he was
the guy that i had helped out at a
dealership we both got dropped in a
dealership basically got lost our jobs
at other dealerships and both ended up
this dumpy water i mean it rained inside
it's hard it rained outside it was a
really bad deal it's called university
ford it's gone now but we were both
getting cheated by our group leaders
because each side of the shop had a
different group and you know we kind of
teamed up with friends and you know i
never saw him again he needed a ride the
last time i saw that guy jameson's
coming is actually the last time i saw
him he needed a ride to go pick up his
motorcycle motorcycle shop well that
dealership sold and they closed it
almost for all right after we started
there so he went a separate way he went
back to california and i went did
something else and then here i run into
the guy at the interview at the
at the tesla motors it's a little bit
weirder that interview went because the
guy that was the director of service at
the time greg zangie was also
the past i don't know if he's a world
guy for ducati and i in 19 2001 i had a
ducati 99 916
that the bolts on the bike were all
corroding and ducati says oh you know
that that was one of six bikes that was
shipped from italy without the silica
packs in the in the bag so they said
well you know we're gonna get we're
gonna take your bike so this guy flies
from new jersey which i think is
completely crazy he comes to my house
which i think is even crazier he takes
my bike don't meet the guy i don't see
the guy i'm at work he calls me up two
days later said i'm not getting my bike
back and i'm thinking what's up with
this
so
he goes oh you know we're going to buy
you a new bike we're going to give you a
new bike so i went down to seattle
ducati and there my new bike was sitting
brand new bike no charge to me
and they did that so
greg zangie asked me to tell the best
customer service story he i had ever had
so i tell the story about how ducati and
i still don't have an understanding why
not he did all this greg zangie was adam
fawcett's boss
greg zangie's the person who made the
decision to give me that new ducati and
i didn't even know the guy wow so years
later i run into jamison cummings and
greg zangie which i never met greg
before i run into these two they're
they're interviewing me at tesla so it's
just like the stars aligned yeah it
starts the line and here we are that's
how i ended up with that job before we
go into that we got to thank our sponsor
ftxus as you guys as i'm sure have seen
crypto has declined a lot over these
last few months which means now could be
a great time to buy in but you got to
find a reputable brokerage of which ftx
us is there to help they're used by
millions of users to buy sell track and
trade both crypto and to nfts all in one
place with fees that are up to 85
percent lower than the top competitors
and jack hates fees right jack i hate
fees with a passion how much do you hate
fees i probably hate them 12 out of 10.
yeah jack i'll show you how easy it is
uh all you got to do is select what you
want to buy how often you want to buy it
how much you want to buy and then swipe
right and you're completely done plus
you get free crypto on every single
trade you make over ten dollars and guys
this is a secret but they're soon
launching ftx stocks so they're going to
be an all-in-one inclusive finance app
where you can trade crypto nfts and
stocks all in one place it's gonna be
amazing definitely check it out with
that link below they also allow you to
do automatic recurring buys that you
could dollar cost average to the markets
on a regular basis i think that feature
is incredibly important because timing
the market accurately is pretty much
almost not going to happen but if you
dollar cost averaging over time you ride
the entire market as a whole so do what
we do and start trading crypto and nfts
with low fees today by downloading the
ftx app with the link down below in the
description again the link is down below
in the description to get started today
and now with that said let's get back to
the podcast and you got interviewed by
six people you said uh at least six and
one of those was elon well yeah the last
person what was that like it was fun
he's a really nice he's actually a
really good guy i mean he's incredibly
smart so he's intimidating in that in
that regard but if you look at him based
on his kids the guy loves his kids he
loves his family he's a good dad and
he's just easy to talk to we have to say
we've had a conversation and i got the
job and
that's after the whole paypal thing so
he was i mean you already knew who he
was and everything he knew who he was
but he was still um if you look at the
pictures he uh he uh was young a lot
younger yeah and uh you know what he had
some very for a guy not from the car
industry and never worked at a car
dealership he had some very good
questions and i answered all of his
questions and somehow were some of the
questions
uh just basically like a customer
service you know what are the what are
the some of the pitfalls you've
experienced in the service industry you
know what did you do to overcome those
kinds of things and he asked me
questions basically what was the problem
and how did you solve the problem i
think he was trying to figure out what
my problem uh solving processes were
like and then i um you know i told him
about because i had the highest customer
satisfaction in the world at the lincoln
mercury dealerships i worked at i beat
out four or we did i don't want to take
credit for everything without a nice
team we uh i managed a team that we beat
up four thousand seven hundred other
dealerships worldwide for customer
service from ford they gave me a trip to
cause they were trying to co-op me they
gave me a crypt of cozumel and a trip to
maui and a bunch of other stuff how do
you get so good at customer service like
graham has to practice this with his
courses like let's say someone requests
a refund graham's really good he's like
hey i'll give you a refund it's always a
21 day window he's very good at that but
how do you get to that next level of
customer service i know you gave the
example of the ducati guys who just came
picked it up and gave you a new one but
what do you do that's so special yeah
how do you prevent getting taken
advantage of because sometimes there
there are those circumstances where you
know it's
you know false and you don't want to be
taken let's just say i probably do that
a little bit different than you would
about yeah okay so the reality is i
already know people who are getting take
nice guys i've been a nice guy my whole
life i've helped a lot of people i'm not
bragging about that i'm just saying i do
so you kind of get the signs you get the
you know i already knew they were going
to take advantage of me but i let him do
it anyway sometimes and then i'll just
tell them about it you know i already
knew that your ac condenser wasn't
damaged and i already knew from the
paint on your front bumper
that we didn't do this and the car was
wrecked after it was here but we're
going to go ahead and take care of that
anyway
and then they just feel like complete
dirt because they've gotten a lie and
half them when most time when i call
them out they'll pay for it wow but i do
it in a nice way i do it i don't try to
humiliate him oh maybe it was an honest
mistake you know
what i know so you let people get away
with lies or in deception you just do
your job chug away and then of course
you know you mention it to him but it
tends to work in your favor it always
works in my favor usually we do this
straight with people people we're just
seeing everybody's adults right if you
just have you know there's i read a book
a long time ago called difficult
conversations so you just got to have
him he's got to be respectful no name
calling you know don't make any
accusations hey this is what happened
this is what i found oh yeah i i forgot
i ran into the back of that semi truck
and you know wiped my car off at the
windshield it was an honest mistake you
know just made all that up but the truth
is
you catch it you catch them and what are
you supposed to do you can't you don't
want to ruin your future business right
i also wrote another book called
customer for life it was an old
dealership book back in the 90s but you
know what every customer was for life
you treated them like you know you may
lose this time but you're going to gain
next time
and that's one of the things we do here
we just sometimes we lose now the
community i've noticed is very tight
and you've been describing these cars as
like oh that's number two four five and
that's this one you know every car by
number with their owner and you were
explaining something that i found really
interesting uh linking up two customers
together two owners of the roadster
together who have never met each other
or trading their cars basically
temporarily to drive one back to the
other who have never met so a really
strange coincidence here today which
doesn't happen ever
before is we have vin's 905 which is the
car you just purchased and we have been
906 here we also have vin 687 here which
is
the vin number directly after the car
that's in space which has been 686. a
guy called me
one of the cars is from a really small
town in canada so a guy called me this
morning while we were chatting it up and
i went outside to take the phone call
the guy called me and he goes look i've
got this car in the city and i don't
know i'm gonna get it to you
because i'm gonna leave for a couple of
months and i don't have to get it back
either
and i said well that's funny because
we've got a car here from that same town
you've got to keep in mind it's a very
small town
and in canada so we've got a car here
from that same town let me get a hold of
that guy and see if he can drive your
car down and take his back so i got a
three-way phone call made it happen and
nobody nobody never met each other
before and you know what that guy the
other guy's handed his keys to this guy
because he's gonna bring his car down
swap it for his own
this is a really tight community i i
would imagine that any roadster owner
could go to any country in the world and
get whatever they needed they need a
ride no problem i guarantee somebody
will come get them
how many roadsters were made 2500 2450
is about the reason i can't say
definitely was there some production
gaps
and changes like some validation
prototypes were built during production
time mm-hmm
um and then the six there was a little
bit of so i don't know exactly the
number and i'm not going to lie about it
because i don't i think right there are
people out there who claim they have the
number but i was i haven't actually seen
the hard numbers i want to see in
writing now is this card developed when
elon musk took over tesla
during during okay before and during
okay so could you describe that some of
the history behind so one of the yeah
one of the things if you look at these
cars some of them early cars have a
shifter
and the later cars have push button
drive okay well they needed to make
one of the reasons that martin eberhard
and elon musk didn't see eye to eye was
build cost now if you look at the
connections on a 215 101.5 version of
this car
all the electronic connections are all
mild military grade twist locks they're
even green actually and they're
watertight i mean they're really the top
of the top right of the best you could
buy so we needed a elon and this is
before my time elon needed to let make
the cars less expensive to manufacture
so they took out the shifter which was
an 1800 savings
they took out the little tray coin tray
which you don't have and they took out
they added a glove box plastic glove box
plastic tray got rid of a big piece of
aluminum that went across there so
anyway they brought the prices down on
these cars as two they were a where they
could break even on them and not lose
but it was costing like 110 000 just to
build them and they were selling for 90
to 125 the most highly optioned cars
were 160. but so the early development
of the tesla could you describe when
elon musk took over tesla what was the
company the company was not selling the
company was doing events showing the car
but they hadn't sold a bunch of them yet
they were on weak knees we were having
trouble making payroll
you know
uh tesla was you know
in
june of 2010 they shipped
a bunch of us and probably 25 of us to
to the uk to go help put these cars
together so part of the problem with the
lotus factory was they had a break room
that was about a 20 minute walk
from
the production floor and they had to
start their breaks when they got to the
is how we were explained is they didn't
get to start their break the clock
didn't start taking on their break until
they actually got to the breakup which
is a 20 minute walk 20 minute there 30
minute break 20 minute back what are you
at 30 50 70 minutes now right yeah for
for three breaks so there's 240 minutes
210 minutes that aren't being
produced in the lotus factory because
these guys are always on break so they
sent us there and we're all much flat
right technicians if you guys know what
that mean you get paid by what you do
and the faster you go the more money you
make so all of us are old flat rate
technicians so we go into the lotus
factory we start making waves and they
basically said take off your pedestal
jackets we don't want you here so the
base they want to kick us out of the
factory but you know the powers that be
i'm assuming elon at the time you know
we're
kicking them back in the line saying no
no they're going to work on those cars
and there was a guy i don't want to
mention his name uh glenn
one of us went around so these cars were
all painted with
uh in pieces and there were there was
masking tape on the back side of every
one of these panels or permanent marker
written on the back of every one of
these panels
and they would put the cars together and
whatever they were but the guys that
lotus were actually hiding parts because
they were pissed off at us because we
were getting the cars out they were
hiding the parts so a guy named glenn he
goes around the factory and he finds a
hood that we needed for a car to put it
together it's got the vend number
written on the hood so we put on the car
they came back the next morning had an
explosion they were so mad at us for
you're stealing parts you're doing this
you're doing that it's like
there are parts we're not stealing
anything we're just doing what we're
here to be paid to do so i i think the
only reason tesla survived was all those
guys who went to the uk there was i i
would say there's probably ten different
events that made tesla barely survive
and we
you know that was the a team you worked
at tesla early on you're the best there
was period how long did you stay with
tesla for i stayed there until 2013.
what happened then decided to leave on
your own uh no i got fired i uh
basically i um my boss was
going out of his way um to make sure
that we were not getting the cars out
the door he um
backing up to march of 2012 i had sent
out i had to send out an email to
all everybody in service
and parts i need to know what your last
service ranger services mobile service
visit how long it took the time you
picked up the phone until the time you
you know parked the vehicle and you were
done with that that deal and it became
it came it was nine hours per car for a
ranger to come take the phone call get
the parts load the van go to the car
come back it was nine hours
so what happened was we didn't get to
staff so we're down at the factory
setting up for the 2012 model s's a lot
of us and the cars were coming off the
line as a disaster like i just described
to you and we didn't have anybody to
because there was no staff there was no
extra staff anywhere that we needed
staff i ended up pulling 32 people from
all over the world i was spending
basically a hundred thousand dollars a
month at the fremont marriott hotel
to
house these people and defeat them and i
got trouble for feeding these guys and
he goes they need to take a break and i
said they don't want to take a break
because well legally they have to take a
break and i said i know and legally
they're taking a break he goes well you
need to make sure that every one of
those guys goes out and eats and being
gone an hour well keep in mind we need
to have 4 000 cars out and we were
working 100 hour weeks so for us to stop
and eat three meals a day was just gonna
kill three or four hundred of those cars
getting out the door and we we barely
made it we were there until midnight
on the 2012 to get that 4000 car out the
door we didn't have any extra time so i
was buying food on my company credit
card to feed everyone and i was spending
like 300 bucks at lunch to feed
everybody we were buying like banquet
buffet type stuff it wasn't horrible it
wasn't too expensive i got trouble for
that
because he told me that they could they
had to go down and eat and it was
basically a way to to nail me on my
company credit card but first we gotta
thank our sponsors storyblocks guys
we've been using storyblocks for about
two years now and i mean it when i say
it has helped the workflow of this
business tremendously storyblocks is a
subscription service that gives you
instant access to millions of
high-quality royalty-free hd and 4k
footage templates images sound effects
you name it i cannot tell you the
countless hours i've literally just
wasted looking for the perfect stock
footage or sound effects for my edit
well with story blocks that is no longer
an issue i've been able to reinvest this
time i've saved from story blocks back
into my creative visions and to make
content that i'm truly proud of and
whether you're part of a large media
company or just trying to jumpstart your
next creative passion projects
storyblocks is the perfect solution with
your flexible and scalable subscription
plans you could start creating content
with the tools you need without having
to worry about a budget plus their
unlimited all-access plan lets you
downloaded unlimited assets from all
three of their libraries guys seriously
we've been loving and using storyblocks
for about two years now and we are so
excited that they reached out to sponsor
us creative burnout is a real thing and
creative inspiration does not have to be
so taxing learn more about how you can
take your editing to the next level when
you visit storyblocks.com ich again
that's storyblocks.com
ich or you could just use the link down
below in the description thank you so
much storyblocks and back to the podcast
and then the second thing that happened
was there was a car in hawaii that was
all scratched up it was delivered hawaii
all scratched up but the car was sold in
seattle so i actually ended up knowing
the lady and then when i got promoted i
found out that lady had never driven the
car because he'd been sitting at kona
hawaii all scratched up so my oldest son
had just gotten married i went to my
boss and said hey you're only giving me
five hundred dollars total to detail
this car nobody in kona hawaii is going
to detail this car 500 bucks they won't
do it and you know she lives in las
vegas part time and she lives in kona so
she can't get the car there what should
we do i'll figure it out that's your
problem so an email came to me from
somebody way high up at tesla and says
fix the problem
because this lady had contacted elon
and so somebody downhill had gotten the
message i was told to go to hawaii so i
went back to my boss and my boss said i
don't care what he says you're not going
to hawaii for more than 500
i said we need to take care of this lady
she's in her third year of owning this
car and she still has not been able to
drive because it's so scratched up so we
got approval on an email exchange for
hundred dollars did they would tesla
would pay one
way of that flight of the trip to kona
because he was going there for honeymoon
if he would detail the car for free
so we shipped all the chemicals the
buffer the polisher everything we needed
to take care of a car what sandpaper no
matter how bad it was my son goes there
before he goes on his honeymoon he fixes
this lady's car she's raving about us
she loves i was just so happy
my boss looks at me and goes you're not
going to live through this
like what you authorize this because no
i didn't so i got fired he told hr that
that trip was not authorized
we got fired both of us was in about two
minutes of each other we got fired for
an unauthorized trip to hawaii and the
truth was so i told tesla's
legal i said look i won't sue you if
you'll go and read my email and that
that guy's thread because i had a folder
just for this guy it was so bad in my
outlook and i said if you'll read that
folder for an hour a day for a week
at the end of the week you tell me what
you found
or whatever you whatever you say to me
but in a week we'll talk again
and if you feel like that everything is
as it should have been no problem i'm
not going to sue anybody but i just want
to i want you to read it so you know
where i was coming from and to know that
that was a legitimate trip so they did
that and the guy got demoted three times
but he still kept his job so
that's how i got fired to tesla was
being lied about wow it was it was
cutthroat back there because
tesla had gotten this feet on the ground
they had already created this massively
good service team these guys are the
best and the best nationwide worldwide i
mean still these guys are a players
everywhere
i mean a lot of these guys have gone are
lucid they're the top dogs at lucid and
riviera now in other places because they
were so good so tesla legal the two
lawyers read
that folder and uh i never got my job
back i probably could have um at that
time i was too pissed off why weren't
they fixing your car
why would they do that to you like
what's the what's the motive so the the
first thing was
i was sent to santa monica before this
promotion that i got to fire the santa
monica service manager because this guy
my boss didn't like him
so i he used me as his hatchet man they
fired him and bob had told me the guy's
name was bob that guy had told me that
he'd been trying for two years to get
somebody hawaii but they wouldn't let
them take anybody they wouldn't give him
a budget to do it so my boss had been
for two years to mess with my the guy
that i had to terminate just to mess
with him he was making that lady pay
that's the kind of guy he was he's doing
that everywhere oh why he's just that
guy how did you fall into doing this
was this right after you got fired you
decided you wanted to
get into roadsters no actually strangely
enough the guy called while we were
having lunch yeah um david vazqvich a
close friend actually
uh
he called me said he want to get his
roster working he goes no he's working
on my car but you and
then he talked to another guy and then
another guy and you know eventually
we have all of them not all of them but
there's 37 of them here i think today
was that legal for you to work on a
tesla car after working for them like on
the side they sued me they tried to sue
me and yeah basically wrote go after
yourself on the envelope send it back i
never heard another word about that
really yeah well they originally tried
to say it wasn't qualified yes and then
what they didn't know was i was one of
the one of the people that were
certifying body shops at the time i mean
they were there was the main guy that
did it but occasionally you know they'll
be an outlier right so here's my
signature on the bottom of this form
right so i have the body shop
certification form and it's like so if
i'm incompetent to work on the cars
how was i competent enough to train the
people to work on the cars how did that
work
and then they're like white as ghosts
and that was it that was the end of my
conversation with tesla legal and what
do you think the issue was that they
didn't want someone who wasn't within
their organization working on the car or
they were just trying to stamp this car
out and get rid of it it was it was all
based on how i was terminated right i
was terminated for stealing
right so they don't want somebody with
that credibility problem working on
their cars so that's why they went after
me the truth was i never stole anything
that was proven later but i think the
legal team just figured that i was every
i think they assumed that what hr did
and what this guy did was legal because
hr did it right you know and they didn't
even that lady didn't check anything
nobody verified i even asked her in
front my laptop was a foot from where
she was sitting to fire me i asked her
to look at that email no no no that's
already but it's already been made
she wouldn't do it
jeez
so you started off with one customer one
car where were you doing the work from i
have another business about 1.3 miles
from here right now we're building
street rods out of there yeah about
electric street rods
gosh okay
started with that word of mouth
how long did it take you to
get something like this we were
it's kind of funny how this happened so
the owner of this building is also the
owner of my other building he owns a
token he stands towing so stan um
retired eventually this was a warehouse
where they stored this this building did
not have water
sewer or power in it there was
one
two outlets in the ceiling with two
light bulbs that's always in here it was
used for storing direct cars and
impounds that's all this was for
and uh so the owner of this this uh
property said you know
you've always been good to me how about
you know you want to use that warehouse
like i looked at this place and you know
we used 30 gallons of degreaser because
this had never had water would never be
cleaned it was an oil before it was hit
a tow yard it was an oil
storage depot for uh home oil for like
furnaces and stuff it was oil all over
in here it was disgusting so you
couldn't walk in without getting dirty
but he gave it to me because it was so
bad for thirteen hundred dollars a month
on a really long lease and i thought for
thirteen hundred dollars a month i'm
gonna rip this place apart and put
everything new that's what i did it cost
me sixty thousand dollars i had an
estimate from a contractor for four
hundred thousand to do what you see here
yeah and it was sixty thousand in parts
and labor because i hired all the
homeless uh you know i found out kind of
chatted up with the homeless to find out
which ones used to work for construction
and stuff i hired them paying them cash
every day they loved it wow and now
we're uh they've gotten back on their
lives they're back on their back on
their feet and they're off doing other
things now and so when tessa sells a car
like this
do they agree that they'll always be
available to service the car or how does
that work there used to be a federal law
that people had to manufacture the
supply parts for 10 years that law i
don't think
is in existence anymore and the magnuson
act where right to repair doesn't really
really qualify either i mean if you have
one of these cars in your name tesla
legally has to sell you parts but if
they don't have it they don't have it
and they don't have an inventory parts
for these cars
i mean every time i call them zero
so what happens if i take this
the tesla service center and i say
it would
really most most the time
we've had um i can't i don't want to say
the states yeah we've had that'll get
these guys in trouble we've had several
you know
a smart manager a smart technician knows
when they're over their head
instead of getting buried in the car and
wasting time with the other cars they
need to get out like a model threes or
model x and otherwise or plaids or
whatever getting out the front door they
automatically just call and we ship the
cars to us
so there's a couple guys that are pretty
sharp about that they realize that it's
going to cost them money
and time to fix a car they don't know
anything about so they don't do it no
i've heard stories about tesla making
offers to buy customer cars to then part
out they do
so if i took this car into a service
center would they make me an offer or
would they just call you and then if
nothing could be done they'll just make
how does that work it's like a
multi-layered conversation so they would
you'll take it in for service and if you
acted like you wanted to sell it or
trade it in they would give you a
trade-in value for this but they're not
paying very much they've been paying
like like the yellow car that they
poured out they paid like 35 000 for
that car jeez
why are they parting out cars like why
do they want to decrease the amount of
so they threw away
decreasing the cars decreases the amount
of parts that they'll need in the future
right and so they parted out 53 cars
basically because they owed people
batteries 3 0 battery upgrades and they
didn't have any they didn't have any
battery cases or anything and the people
who made this battery case originally
like the black case right there the
people that made that case that was a
that was a barbecue manufacturer that
made that case for tesla
so they're not going to do it again and
so there wasn't any so they had to to
fulfill their requirements their legal
requirements for the 3-0 battery packs
they had to part out at least a few of
the cars to get exchange battery packs
to get started so they could put new
sheets in the batteries and new
stuff but that's why they bought i don't
that and they don't have any parts so
early early on they threw away 13
million worth of parts or that's what i
was told and now they need an inventory
of something
i mean if they're going to work on the
cars they have parts too so how many
teslas do you have we own 12 and
probably eight parts cars what's the
total worth of all of your teslas
currently
and what was it like three years ago
three years ago twelve teslas would've
been worth five hundred thousand dollars
tops
now they're probably worth
two million i would think and what's
your prediction for the the future value
of these cars i feel like if you know
obviously it's such a tough question to
answer but if anyone's going to have a
good estimation if you look at history
you look at shelby mustangs or gts ac
cobras z28 camaros you look at the
anything that's rare in low production
and a gear head can get their arms
wrapped around their mind wrapped around
it they're going to buy it they want to
buy it but as far as the values of these
cars you know as long as they're still
drivable you know these are going to be
i would say in five years is going to be
a bunch of these in museums you know i
had a pretty famous person bring me
their car about a year ago and say
look
i don't want this thing i don't want to
sell it you know this guy's worth
billions and he just said i don't want
any more
what's the cheapest you ever bought a
roadster for
and i said the cheapest ever bought one
for was ten thousand dollars he goes
that's what you're going to pay for mine
and i said ah
that's not fair to you and he drove it
here
right so billionaire drove their tesla
yesterday and i said uh
what do you what are you thinking he
goes 10 grand write me a check for 10
grand what's your pay for it
because getting rid of this car is worse
than having a yard sale to me you know
it's just i gotta drive it around and
find a home for it and he goes and i
thought of you and you know what this is
the home was there anything wrong with
it no
just had a new battery put on it what
goes on through your mind just like
acquiring like the 10th one the 11th one
the 12th one like is there any desire to
continue buying these cars or is it just
the idea of buying them you just want
more i want all of them and
is there any part in your mind that's
like okay you know if i buy this car i
can hold on to it it'll be a good
investment and i can sell it in the
future for a better price or is it just
like you know opportunity comes up sure
why not i'll just get my
we often we often run ourselves down to
zero dollars around here um we have we
have all this because everything is we
don't have any debt the only debt we
have is whatever's on the credit card
from this month right now that's the
only debt this company has so what we do
is we take our profits and we buy parts
cars or other cars
and right now there are two cars coming
up
which is part of the reason i sold this
car there are two cars coming up for me
to buy for screaming deals i could
trouble my money on them so i buy them
one thing that's interesting to me is
that you would expect
electric cars especially like since this
was one of the first ones uh to have so
many issues what are some of the most
common issues that you find in in the
original tesla roadster the most common
issue is people not playing and let them
go dead so every other tesla has the
ability to restart charging if the car
if you have a power outage power goes
off if you stop the charging on one of
these cars it will not restart you have
to go back and restart it and if you
don't do that three months later the
battery's dead that's the biggest
problem but it's self-inflicted as far
as uh the cars breaking
the pems the power electronic module is
that's what controls the
ac to dc voltage and all that stuff that
that component wears and
some of the electronic components age
out we repair those that's the biggest
thing so how do the batteries die like
that like if you don't plug it in what's
how quickly do you have to get it back
and when is the point of no return uh
when you hear if you ever walk by this
car and it goes
it's a very distinct that car's killing
itself that's the final warning before
it actually shuts the whole car down and
says this battery is smoked graham
posted on his instagram story asking for
short quick questions that we can ask
our very special guest today so we're
gonna get on to instagram rapid fire
question and answer okay uh are you
gonna buy the new roadster when it comes
out no why it's too expensive i'll build
one all right
let's see what do you dislike about the
roadster i don't have more of them
if you could say something though that
like
something that could be improved uh all
the things that could be improved on
those cars we have improved like the
suspension was awful it handled awful in
a corner you throw one of these things
down in a corner you're better but just
pray
but now we've changed we've changed all
the shocks and the valving and the
springs and we have that all dialed in i
think it was the one thing that uh i
would too weak on these cars as a
suspension what was the lowest vin
you've ever worked on i worked on aliens
car event too really why did you work on
elon's car well he left it at the uh
i don't know how this happened but he
left at the fremont marriott hotel and
he wanted it brought back or bought
someplace and i i ended up moving the
car that car had its own
group of people
what was that like working for elon it
was fun yeah you know he's he's an off
if if he wants micromanager you you're
probably on your way out really you know
because he hires good people let him do
their thing
he's smart but he also knows how to hire
smart people was he social in the
workspace or does he kind of keep to
himself he wasn't social at all i mean
he would talk to you if he needed to
talk to you but he didn't just go to bs
with people at all i'm even in meetings
he was
would he ever joke around or anything i
never saw it
so he was very like stoic and strict he
was very very i think he was very
disciplined
when i was how i would put it
i you know i i stayed in the framework
at hotel for almost six months straight
while they were setting up the factory
and stuff and elon's kids stayed there
too
and uh you know
one of the respectful things that
everybody at tesla did which i thought
was just without even saying it he had
this old if you go to the freeman hotel
you go on the front door and hard to the
right there's a bunch of little cubby
you can sit back in the corner back
there that's where him and his kids went
and you know what nobody disrespected
him nobody went over there and talked to
him when he was with his kids nobody
said a word the place was quiet
everybody catered to him to his kids and
him
and uh it was just i i i admire the guy
for the way he took care of his kids it
was uh you know that's the side that's
the side of elon and everybody not
everyone gets to see yeah how is that
because it seems like in
a lot of the the media that we see he's
he's absent from his kid's life and he's
always working and it seems like he's
sleeping on the floors
uh did you see a different side i
actually saw him sleep on a desk once um
i deleted the photo i should have kept
the photo but i deleted a photo out of
respect i took the picture and i thought
oh my god you're getting fired for this
so i deleted the photo
but uh he's a human being right i mean
he's got
uh hopes and dreams and you know the way
he'd say is the worst thing you could
ever do in the in the world to start a
car company i wouldn't recommend it and
you know it's tough i mean he went from
having an easy life i wouldn't say it
was easy but you know being a car
manufacturer and all those bottlenecks
and stuff he had to work through it's
astonishing that he has gone this far
but he hires good people he really does
hire good people you think that's one of
the biggest keys to running such a
successful business is the ability to
hire well i think it's the ability wire
hire well but there's more to it than
that so like
everybody that i heard at tesla's never
got fired unless they got railroaded
the reality is to hire the right people
for a position like it would be easy for
you to hire a videographer or somebody
else because you have a lot of
experience in that space
for me it was easy because i'd done
every job at
that you could possibly do in the auto
repair industry so the guy you know
every time he was trying to bs me it's
like come on yes give me the truth you
know
but the truth is i can hire people
because i knew what i was looking for i
would hire somebody like i would hire a
guy that was a ex-service advisor
ex-service manager ex-service advisor
x this and i'd put him in a position of
leadership so if his team got into
trouble he could go out and help him and
that's so i hired one guy that could do
four jobs
that was the key to hiring for me and i
that's what i did and we called we they
called our team to get get [ __ ] done to
him the gsd team because all the people
that were around me i surrounded myself
with were all those same people you just
all you have to do is point the red one
over there and you never thought about
it again you never had to check on any
of their work nothing ever not once
so really good people is the best it's
the only way that he survived have you
ever refused to service a roadster yeah
actually i have oh is that story we've
had some problems with uh people feel
entitled you know sometimes they'll come
here and they think that uh
you know because they're worth 100
million dollars and they've got that way
by cheating everyone that they think the
best way to handle that situation is to
cheat me too and i just cut them off
okay who are you i'll fire you you're
talking down to me or one of my kids or
you're being disrespectful or you don't
want to pay your bill you're not a
customer you're definitely not a good
customer so i keep you is the new one
ever going to get made
that's a good question i'm going to say
yes to that because i've never seen elon
not do what he said he was going to do
i don't know what the hold ups are
probably i would assume that sales
would be a hold up even though people
like
a sports car two-door cars are the the
lowest sales of any manufacturer's cars
sports cars everybody likes sports cars
everybody likes to ride sports cars and
drive them
but very few people can afford to buy
them for a second
for a first vehicle yeah will it get
built i think it's going to get built
probably 20 23 i'm skeptical because he
also promised to give so many of them
away for people who did through the you
know the referral program i think he
owes like 100 roadsters at this point
that might be an issue yeah so i think
that's going to be an issue the other
issue i see is that when he got rid of
that program he said that there is going
to be a raffle every 30 days depending
on how many uh referrals you bring in
you're going to have a chance to win a
brand new model why we're going to give
away you know these cars as far as i'm
aware he never did that i never once saw
anything that indicated he ever gave
away a car it's just kind of a knee-jerk
reaction in my opinion because back when
these cars know about vin 600 each range
whatever time period and
time that was they weren't selling
okay so tesla came up with a bank
america lease program for these cars
so with a lot of some released and that
sounds like the same kind of gimmick to
get sales up i don't know to be true but
yeah that's what i would from what i've
seen before so i'm skeptical about the
the roadster ever coming into production
because i think by the time maybe it
does it's going to be outdated and they
have to
do it again
and maybe bring out something different
yeah i mean how much
not everybody needs a track car
i mean a 10 second car like the plan is
i mean it took 150 200 000 to build one
of those if you want your own street car
there was a 10-second car yeah and now
you just go down and turn the key but
not everybody has those driving skills i
think if you're going to own applied you
better go to school
because people are taking those things
off-road with you know they're fast yeah
what's the maintenance on this car every
year it has a 600
annual service
and the funny story behind the annual
maintenance on that car is about
2009 i would say major niche people were
asking what was the service going to be
what was annual maintenance going to be
in tesla never even thought about amanda
yet so they created this service which
is really much a fluff
600 service includes a wiper blade a
bunch of testing and the washer
reservoir cleaned and you know it's just
ridiculous stuff you can get in a quick
loop right that's what the service and a
bunch of measuring we did a bunch of
hypot testing you know but
that was those tests were needed for the
first couple years but these cars
approved themselves they don't need to
do those testing anymore so what's the
annual maintenance basically nothing
resetting the light putting a wiper
blade on checking the tires and
you know basic overview do you ever have
plans to make a battery yourself where
you could replace individual cells
we actually duplicated this battery
already can't get it out of the china
tariffs but eventually you'd be able to
that's our goal in a new batch i was
gonna uh i was gonna send an email elon
an email and ask him about that because
if he's gonna build the batteries for
him i don't want to but if they're not
gonna build him i'm going to that blows
my mind so you just you just send elon
an email
just him yeah
just casually i'll send him an email no
no no no no no no no hold on okay you
tell him to subscribe to the iced coffee
hour podcast it's like hey uh you might
know graham steph and he just bought the
yellow roadster elon tesla
that's it musk at tesla.com i wouldn't
be surprised if it's something
yeah
mr musk i wouldn't be surprised if it's
something like really easy like that
yeah that's crazy that you could just
casually say hey man are you going to
create the batteries it gets better
could you share your last text with elon
musk
i still have all this contact no way
is that a cell phone number is that like
a
really yeah
no way he just answers that though i i
he i this is the same he interviewed me
on this phone
he interviewed me so
i had his number and everybody elon was
elon used to even
in public would tell people his email
address because he wanted to hear the he
wouldn't hear the straight scoop from
people he doesn't like things being
filtered or any kind of bs coming his
way he likes the truth why do you save
his name as elon musk are you ever
worried that like if your phone gets
stolen or something that happens is
someone like because people i think it's
important i mean
alex's contact in your phone is elon
musk oh
that is true
that is true i literally have alex saved
in in my phone as elon musk
that is funny people aren't going to
think oh this right yeah
actually has jack and elon musk like
no one's going to think that i'd say
he's fine doing that yeah yeah i don't
know i mean he's just a regular guy you
know when you work with him
there's no celebrity status going on
it's it's like i need that done
in five minutes
and in four minutes you hand it back to
him there you go
the way it was he likes people to get it
done he doesn't he doesn't need to know
me i've contacted him once since i left
tesla
what was that one time for
i was asking i needed some parts
and uh you know what that i did was
right before the first cnbc video in
2019
and the next week
they were selling me parts
it's that fast mentioned on the video i
sent it to him in a message the next
thing i know is carl mellix buying parts
from tesla i'd went three years with no
parts at all nothing it's so cool
is there anything else you could tell us
uh from your experience working with
elon um we don't argue with him when
elon makes when elon stands up at the
end of a meeting and said this is the
direction we're gonna go you better get
out of your chair and you better have
that direction whatever the direction
that is you better go
because he's not one for people back
talking he'll just let you go you're
just gone
and i actually saw that happen actually
would you ever see him just straight up
fire people on the spot i saw him fire
somebody we were we were in a meeting
and it was early on at tesla and they
were trying to convince people
this person was trying to convince
people that um they needed service
centers in these locations these
location legal locations
and elon said well we're going to do
this
and that person kept talking and never
saw the person again
that also happened during my interview
one of the people who interviewed me i
never saw again he's friends with me on
facebook i didn't know he didn't work at
tesla until a year later because i
didn't know anybody that worked a tesla
in the first place right so they're all
new faces to me
and so so i go on going through my
interview list i'm like i took notes
right oh my god what happened to this
guy he got fired as soon as he walked
out of the door for interviewing me they
can't him that's the way it works you
know what he said
the mask
was just curious what he did to me so i
was like what
[Laughter]
i think the elon musk stuff is is
so fancy it's so different to hear about
it it's so detached from what we're
doing yeah yeah it's like you constantly
are hearing about elon musk obviously we
idolize him because he runs the biggest
company you know he's
seems like a great guy doing so much
what happened by the way to the uh tesla
shop in arizona that burned down i don't
know you know i don't know the actual
details all i know is that shot burned
in 2017 then in october you know i don't
know what happened but i'm going to
assume that they the first fire
was you know lithium ion doesn't burn up
by like sparks that doesn't do anything
to a lithium ion but if you heat a
lithium ion battery with a like a air
dryer or a heat gun you know it's
thermal runaway that's what you're
talking about so when that once that
thermal run away have you ever watched
the video on thermal right away you
probably should it's scary it'll scare
you they'll go from zero
uh you know whatever the ambient
temperature is in the room to 2300
degrees within a few seconds and uh that
so what happens when one thermal runaway
happens there's 6831 cells in this car
right when one of them thermal runaways
then it just keeps the rest of them run
away and then you then it tags every
other car so my my thought was and i
don't know but my thought was that they
were charging a battery and it had a
resist of selling it recharging a sheet
and it shorted and it
created the heat you know resistance
creates heat and then heat it combusted
i think that's what burned the shop down
but i don't know how do you prevent that
from happening here well we do a couple
of things uh number one we don't even go
across the street to 7-eleven with
anything charging
we don't go anywhere with anything
charging in this building we don't
charge at night
we don't we have some safety protocols
and what we do is there's two people
like that car right there
will get turned off before it leaves we
leave we just don't charge anything
we're not around it's you know it's just
about being diligent about being
focused on what you're doing yeah but
what about for a homeowner who charges
this in their garage and they they're
out of town for a few weeks so if the
car will charge at all they don't have
any resistive cells okay they'll um
it'll it'll avoid that brick or it will
um that she will the car will only
charge up to a level that's safe i don't
think any one of these has ever burned
up on its own
not that i've ever heard of i think it's
important to recognize that anybody that
drives one of these cars
is somebody because look at what they
had to pay you you guys have seen some
of the names right so
what
the other thing is interesting is the
community the facebook group for these
cars
is so tight they're such a nice group of
people i bet you i could say you know i
already know this to be true i could fly
to france right now have a place to stay
i could go to spain and have a place to
stay i go to the uk and play a voice
anywhere in the world there's one of
these cars i could find a place to stay
they're just the doors are open they're
just really nice people it's kind of
funny it reminds me of the board eight
yacht club
you know except
except it's the tesla something like
real value something with real value
guys but it's like you that's the
community i think behind the car yeah
and um there's so few of them made yeah
you know but also i think what i thought
was so cool is just just knowing what
sort of people have owned these cars
reminds me of like the hollywood
boulevard walk of fame where you get the
stars you look down i was like that
person has a tesla why this crazy free
of stuff definitely this one again now i
got my star on the hollywood walk of
fame except with tesla what's your plan
with it where are you gonna put it so
this would go next to the lotus but that
means i can't use that as a filming set
so either the lotus or this have to swap
around
and uh get a garage space so i asked
alex and i said hey alex you got an
extra garage space alex lives close by
what if we made an agreement so it's
free but we can drive the lotus a set
amount of miles per month oh i'd get too
paranoid
i i would get two people you've seen me
draw a stick before man it's plus
insurance i know but it's like maybe
what i'll do is i'll come over and i'll
pull it out what yeah i'll tell you what
if you wanna if you wanna consider
letting
your son jack
take out the lotus on occasion you know
have a little bit of fun
then i would consider you know letting
that park in my garage i'd be open to it
okay and and damages uh
50 50.
there you go
damn damages
damages
oh [ __ ]
we got it on camera
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah i did i was so curious where that
was from it was from jack's chair
[Laughter]
i i
felt like oh my god you have liability
insurance on this place
jack your neck hurts right
[Laughter]
[Music]
i thought that was your screw pump
because the thing is realistically i'll
have both cars in the garage um
but just for filming it would make sense
to have
something open and with a car in the
background and it would also make a lot
of sense you have someone you trust and
you care about and you want them to have
that 23 year old experience
but but you got to compete now without
were you when you had your lotus were
you 23.
were you 20.
you can't drive stick you guys got it
but alex doesn't want to drive the car
that's the thing mine's free
yeah but alex doesn't want to drive a
negotiator i'd watch out
you tell me what you would do in this
situation if you were
graham okay free 150
care
great care of the vehicle i drive stick
very comfortably
who knows
who knows but but he's not gonna drive
it but he's not gonna drive it but free
over here what i would probably do is
i'd offer to buy it from him and let him
use it when he needs to oh no no i don't
want to sell it i can't sell the car
look at him he's like i just traded
cheated him
you see him sell it i actually i
wouldn't be opposed but i can't have
three cars
so ridiculous yes when you put the
hammer down that's what you guys know
huh graham
doesn't put the hammer it's usually on
price related things yeah it's usually
if like they want me to buy something
like no we don't need it yeah uh or like
some business expenses it's usually
business dependency i'm like no we don't
need that and jack wants me to hire more
people and i'm just like i don't like i
don't like to having the overhead i
don't like making payroll
sure i want more people to help us out
here but the reality is you know my kids
want me to hire more people but the
truth is these are going to run out
eventually
right i mean why don't we just work on
our pace that we're working on we'll
stay as a family business and if we get
too big
then we'll hire somebody but right now
we're not too big yeah people are just
waiting and they're not bitching so they
start bitching and then off to do
something cool
that's good yeah thank you so much for
doing this i really appreciate it i
think it'll be fun yeah i i can't wait
to see what you're spending on this on
this yeah because dan i already know
what dan's going to do right and i know
what msnbc is going to do they're going
to try to trick me which they did in the
first video when it wasn't when i told
elon to go [ __ ] himself
so you were watching the first video
it's all i'm sure i've seen it yeah yeah
i told elon said yeah go [ __ ] yourself
why'd you say that on camera because
well i didn't know they were filming
because you don't know when they're
there for three days you don't know what
you know you're like we're just talking
that went right in the video i didn't
know they were filming wow
yeah because they sent me that letter
the cease and desist and all that stuff
and everyone go [ __ ] yourself and send
it back and i've said that right on the
video so when people say look that's
that's a great scene it defines you
perfectly it's like
that's the definition of me carl thank
you so much for coming on i'll link to
all of your information down below in
the description for anyone who wants to
reach out along with your instagram
because you're good at getting back to
uh
getting back to people on instagram also
make sure to add us on instagram along
with a free stock that you can get when
you sign up for public using the
codegram worth all the way up to a
thousand dollars thank you carl for
having us i really appreciate this this
is in seattle so i don't know i don't
know if we mentioned this yet but we are
in oh that's right we came all the way
yeah i'm all the way we traveled so
for you guys
off of a chair for you guys thank you so
much for watching and until next time